مرحبًا، أنا الدكتور سانجاي غوبتا أحد
مقدمي بودكاست Chasing Life على قناة CNN، أنت تكره
صالة الألعاب الرياضية ولا يمكنك العثور على الوقت الكافي للوصول إلى هناك،
أعرف ما تعنيه،
إليك ما قد يساعد في جدولة بعض
فترات الراحة السريعة للأنشطة والقيام بها
كلما فعلت ذلك  يمكن أن تضع في اعتبارك أن العدو
هنا يجلس لفترة طويلة جدًا يمكن أن
يزيد من خطر الإصابة بأشياء مثل
مرض السكري وأمراض القلب وحتى
أنواع معينة من السرطان، لذا فإن مجرد
المشي لمدة خمس دقائق كل نصف ساعة يمكن أن يساعد في
تقليل تلك المخاطر، وفقًا
لدراسة جديدة منشورة.  من قبل
الكلية الأمريكية للطب الرياضي، ويقولون إن المشي
لا يجب أن يكون سريعًا، كل ما
عليك فعله هو النهوض والتحرك.
وجدت الدراسة أن هذه الوجبات الخفيفة قليلة النشاط
كما يسمونها تقلل من
ضغط الدم بكمية كبيرة لدى
البالغين الأصحاء.  وقدمت فائدة أكبر
للأشخاص الذين يعانون من أمراض مزمنة، وإذا كنت
لا تستطيع حقًا مغادرة المكتب، فجرب بعض
تمرينات القرفصاء، مما يعني أنك تنهض وتجلس مرة أخرى
وتفعل ذلك مرارًا وتكرارًا،
يبدو سخيفًا من يهتم بتحريك
جسمك بانتظام  هو ما هو مهم جدًا
للصحة الجيدة ويمكنك سماع المزيد
حول كيفية تحسين صحتك
ومطاردة الحياة أينما تحصل على
ملفاتك الصوتية الأجنبية